In many cultures, surnames are
passed from father to child.
I'm a McLysaght because my
father, my father's father,
and my father's grandfather
were McLysaghts.
Unfortunately, my many female
ancestors don't get recorded.
And in fact, I don't
even know my
great-grandmothers' maiden names.
But there does exist a very
important genetic link between
the women in my family.
And that's found not on the 23
pairs of chromosomes that lie
within the cell nucleus.
Instead, it's found in another
part of the cell called the
mitochondria.
So here it is.
This is a mitochondria.
And this is a component of
cells of eukaryotes.
That's everything
except bacteria.
They're sometimes known as the
powerhouse of the cell.
And that's because they produce
all the chemical
energy, known as ATP, that's
required for metabolism.
But they do other
things as well.
They're involved in signalling
and in cell
growth and cell death.
But one really fascinating thing
about mitochondria is
that they've got their own
little circular genome that's
completely separate from the
other chromosomes in the cell.
It's really very short.
It's about 15,000 times shorter
than chromosome 1.
And it only contains 37 genes,
13 of which are involved in
the energy functions.
And in any one given cell, there
are many mitochondria,
ranging from hundreds to
hundreds of thousands.
But the really fascinating thing
is how they got there in
the first place.
In 1966, a young biologist
called Lynn Margulis noticed
similarities between
mitochondria and free-living
microbes and proposed a theory
on the origins of the
mitochondria.
She suggested that about one and
a half billion years ago,
one bacteria was eaten by
another cell and instead of
being digested, lived inside
the other cell and formed a
mutually beneficial symbiotic
relationship, eventually
becoming the mitochondria.
When Lynn Margulis first
proposed this theory, she
wasn't believed.
And the idea failed
to gain traction.
She showed remarkable
tenacity, however.
And she stuck with it.
Eventually, her perseverance
paid off.
And it was later shown that
the mitochondrial DNA has
similarities to the DNA of
free-living bacteria.
Her endosymbiotic theory
was proven true.
It's disappointing to think that
the reason why this idea
was slow to gain acceptance
is the fact that it was
championed by a woman.
These days, however, it's no
longer considered a crazy idea
and it's in every biology
textbook.
But the mitochondrial DNA
has also helped women be
remembered in another way.
And that's because of its
special inheritance pattern.
And this is that the
mitochondria are provided by
the egg cell but
not the sperm.
And so, much like surnames are
passed from father to child,
mitochondria are passed
from mother to child.
And more than this, the
mitochondrial DNA doesn't
undergo the same recombination
as occurs to the other 23
chromosomes.
So your mitochondrial DNA was
inherited intact from your
mother, who got it from
her mother and so on.
And so this provides a record
of the maternal line right
back to the origins of humans.
So to me, there is a certain
poetry in the way that the
mitochondria links us to our
female ancestors while at the
same time serves as an important
reminder of the
challenges faced by
women in science.